et à présent avec mon plateau célia
gaston go bonsoir de la rédaction de tv
78 on va faire avec vous un focus sur la
4e circonscription des yvelines pour en
connaître les enjeux puisque jusqu au
1er tour de ces élections législatives
qui donc ont lieu ces élections
légistatives 12 et 19 juin le premier
tour c'est donc le 12 juin tv 78,2 vous
aide à y voir plus clair je vais voir
plus clair moi aussi ce soir avec vous
sur cette 4e circonscription quels sont
les déjà les communes qui composent
cette circonscription se dire elle se
situe dans le nord-est du département et
englobe plusieurs communes
carrières-sur-seine chatou croissy sur
seine où il loue sienne marly le roi ou
encore le port marly elle recense
presque senti 1000 habitants alors c'est
une circonscription plutôt de centre
droit en 1988 c'est pierre lequiller
alors vice président du conseil général
des yvelines et maire de louveciennes
qui est élu pour le parti ed f il sera
ensuite réélu jusqu'en 2017 sous
l'étiquette ump puis les républicains il
a décidé de ne pas se représenter en
2017 et c'est donc marie le bec du parti
de la république en marche qui le
succède à 61,39 % des suffrages face à
ghislain fournier alors maire de château
marie le lay qui est candidate à sa
propre succession oui en effet la
candidate sortante a la ferme intention
de retrouver son siège elle est
candidate cette fois sous la bannière
ensemble le parti de la majorité
présidentielle
elle compte approfondir le travail déjà
mises en place lors de son précédent
mandat notamment au niveau du
développement économique des écoles et
de la santé mary le bec par plutôt en
territoire conquis puisque emmanuel
macron est arrivé en tête de toutes les
circonscriptions de toutes les communes
de la circonscription à plus de 35%
alors qui sont les autres candidats
ainsi une majorité de femmes au total
six femmes pour trois hommes parmi les
candidats on retrouve l'avocat écrivain
et chroniqueur charles consignes
personnage médiatique vous l'avez
sûrement entendu dans l'émission des
grandes gueules de rmc ou encore sur le
plateau d'on n'est pas couché il
s'engage maintenant en politique sous
l'étiquette les républicains il avait
d'ailleurs déjà été un soutien actif un
de valérie pécresse qui semble qui pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
c'est donc le seul candidat qui semble
se démarquer même si les scores dans la
circonscription pour valérie pécresse
aux présidentielles ton plutôt autour de
la moyenne du département donc aux
alentours de 9% alors on retrouve aussi
des représentants de partis établis en
france comme sophie le landais pour le
rassemblement national ou encore céline
bourdon militante la france insoumise
pour la coalition ux la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale pour le
reste on retrouve plutôt des petits
candidats comme bénédicte créative et
pour le parti reconquête chloé richard
dembo pour le parti animalistes ou
encore franck morel pour la lutte
ouvrière merci célia et je le précise
premier tour de cette élection
législative gens n'étaient pas sûrs tout
à l'heure mais c'est bien le 12 juin et
le second tour éventuel second tour le
19 juin pour ce scrutin des législatives
merci pour toutes ces précisions